by taking the absolute value squared of the corresponding entry.
And so if just X is measured, then the probability to
obtain a particular outcome a is given by this expression,
we simply some over all of
the possible outcomes b, that could be obtained
if Y was also measured even though it wasn't.
The idea is the same as in
the probabilistic setting.
The probability to get
a particular outcome when X is measured can't
possibly depend upon whether or not Y was also measured.
So this tells us what
the probabilities are for the different possible outcomes.
In addition, there will be some
change in the state of Y as a result of having
performed this measurement on X and having obtained a particular outcome.
So let's take a look at how this works.
Similar to what we did in
the probabilistic setting, we can express the
quantum state vector Psi as you see right here
where Phi a is this vector for each choice of a classical state a of the system X,
we're using the bilinear
of the tensor product just like before.
Only now we've chosen to name
these different vectors Phi a, just for convenience.
We already observed that the probability that the measurement yields
each possible outcome a is as you see right here,
but now we can see that this probability is equal to the Euclid norm
squared of the vector Phi a,
and now as a result of the measurement of X giving a particular outcome a, we have that the quantum state
of the compound system XY
becomes this state that
you see right here.
Just like we had for single systems, the state collapses in essence, but it doesn't collapse
entirely in general,
it only collapses as far as it needs to in order to be consistent
with the measurement of X yielding the outcome a.
The quantum state of Y becomes Phi a normalized meaning that we
divide by its Euclid norm
so that it becomes a unit vector. This is analogous to what happened in the
probabilistic setting where instead of dividing
by the Euclid norm,
we divided by the sum
of the entries of Phi a in order to get a probability vector.
But here because we're
talking about quantum states, we divide by the Euclid norm
to get a quantum state vector.
Let's take a look at a couple of examples to see how this works
for a specific state.
Here's the state that we'll consider. We're assuming that X and Y are Qubits and they're in this particular state Psi.
And let's suppose that X is measured.
We begin by writing the state's
Psi as you see right here, effectively isolating the
standard basis factors of X
and tensing them with whatever we need to in order to get the original state.
Just like in the general
description from a moment ago.
The probability to obtain the outcome zero is the Euclid norm squared
of this vector right here.
The thing that we're tensing to cat zero in our expression of the vector Psi.
And so the probability is three quarters and conditioned on
getting the outcome zero.
The quantum state of
the pair XY becomes this where we normalize the
vector tensor to cat zero,
and that's equivalent to
dividing by the square root of the probability that
we just calculated.
We can then simplify
and this is what we get.
The probability to get the
measurement outcome one is calculated in a similar way.
We take the Euclid arm squared
of this vector right here. The thing that's tensed to cat
one in our expression of Psi
and the resulting
probability is one quarter, which it has to be of course, because our probabilities
have to sum to one.
In this case, the quantum state of XY becomes this where again we're normalizing by dividing by the Euclid norm
so that we obtain this quantum
state vector as a result.
The same method is used
in a symmetric way, if Y is measured instead of X.
Here's the original quantum state vector, and this time because Y
is measured instead of X,
we express the vector Psi
as you see right here, where this time we isolate the
standard basis vectors of Y
rather than X tensing
with whatever we need to to get an expression of Psi.
Going through the calculation, which you can check by
pausing the video if you like.
We see that the probability
to get the outcome zero is Phi8 this time, and here's
the quantum state vector
that results conditioned
upon getting that result.
And the probability to get the
outcome one is three eights, in which case this is
our quantum state vector.
You can use exactly the same method in case you have more than two systems and any proper subset
of them are measured.